syria or another bad actor i think the
president cut through a lot of this when
i first started working with him in my
prior position
he just referred to him as all hostages
if they were an american who was taken
by a government or an organization maybe
an organization that had a state sponsor
behind them
his position is they were hostages they
were being used as bargaining ships and
some way to
either humiliate the us or to punish
someone just because of their status as
a us citizen or
or an attempt to gain ransom for an
organization so that they could further
their terrorist goals and their criminal
activities
and the president's position was and i i
think this is the essence when people
ask what america first means i
i don't think there's any place
pure distillation of how the president
feels about getting our folks home and
he doesn't care why they were there uh
what they were doing when they were
taken hostage he doesn't care about
their background he doesn't care about
their
their political affiliation their
religion if they're there's an american
who's taken overseas
he wants him home and and i think that
he's personally offended
uh that either a government or terrorist
organization would take an american
hostage and so
uh he's made it literally one of the top
priorities i don't think we've ever seen
a
a president put the return of wrongful
detainees or hostages
uh at the top of his foreign policy
agenda his national security agenda
but it makes sense because uh you know
when the president
spends so much time and effort on
individual americans who are taken
abroad
our adversaries understand that uh that
he means business
and our friends know that uh he's gonna
he's gonna put american interests first
and
and i don't think there's more uh a more
important american interest than getting
our citizens home when they've been
wrongfully taken you know one of the
high profile cases that you
mentioned in your earlier comments um is
is one that's unresolved and that is um
the case of austin tice many people
think that he's held in syria there have
been reports of
high-level talks with syria on a number
of fronts but also hostages
you know uh reports that kash patel uh
who's now of course rising in the
department of defense and others has
been involved in this
where do those talks stand now and do
you see a pathway and i'm going to
ask you candidly have the syrians
finally admitted
to having the influence to potentially
get austin thais released
so steve those are all great great
questions and i'd love to talk more
to you and and to the folks who the
viewers on this but uh
i can't really comment on what's
happening at this point i know there
have been press reports about the
high-level uh interactions and that
mr patel and ambassador carson's who
took my job as the special president's
homework for host affairs were in
uh in syria uh what i can tell you is
that we're using every tool
uh every lever we have uh to get austin
out it's been uh
something i thought about every day is
the the hostage envoy and every day is
national security advisor is how we get
mark and deborah's son back to them
uh getting back to his friends and
family in texas it's a it's been a very
frustrating case
uh but we've uh uh we're
we're using every tool whether it's
through allies whether it's through
adversaries whether it's
uh uh i i i it's but
we're we're doing everything we can to
get austin back and we would like to get
him back
uh and i'd like to see him back i know
the president would like to see him back
before he leaves office and uh
but i can't i can't comment further on
the on the case at this time
i i understand that and i i think we all
wish you well in
in those efforts um let me ask you
another question i'm sort of i don't
know where the audience is and we may
lose them in this but i'm a
real nerd and wonk when it comes to
studying the national security council
over many years under very different
leaders
and and i am interested in how you see
the national security decision making
process who needs to be in the room how
is it structured
of course we recently lost brent
scowcroft for many people i knew very
well but
many people look at him as one of the
ideal uh national security advisors and
i'd just be interested in
how you compare the way you've
structured the decision-making process
well maybe
let's pick a few you know uh susan rice
uh
uh us big brzezinski uh brent scowcroft
what what does a president need and
expect and should have in the structural
dimensions of
national security decision making well
when you reel off those names uh the
people that have uh that held the office
before me i think i'm the 28th national
security advisor and uh and there have
been just some
some some giants in american national
security and foreign policy have sat in
that office
many of them have been extraordinarily
kind and sharing their wisdom with me
and
uh and talking about how to organize the
national security council one of the
things i did
is uh when i when i first took office is
i i reached out to a number of my
predecessors uh starting with henry
kissinger and going down and
and predecessors from both sides of the
aisle to ask them uh their thoughts and
to get their insight
uh the one thing i wanted to do and and
all of them confirmed it is i wanted to
follow the model that brent scowcroft
had for the national security council i
think he was a very effective
national security advisor now it i
didn't want to be a cliche though
because every national security adviser
who comes into office is you know steve
having followed this
the first thing they say is we're going
to have the skillcraft model in our
national security council they they may
or may not have the skillcraft model but
everyone that's that's almost like a a
religious incantation
but i really i i i took a look at what
brent did i talked to folks who worked
with brent
uh uh on either his executive secretary
his deputies or others
and i think there are a couple of things
that that
are exemplify the skillcraft model
number one is being an honest broker
i don't think you can have your own
agenda as the national security advisor
and i think when you have your own
agenda you're pushing your own agenda
it makes you less effective as a
convening uh power i mean the
the power i have as a senior staff for
the president is to bring together the
cabinet secretaries the department heads
uh try and get their their very best
views on an issue to get their very best
advice for the president
to get their counsel on what course of
action we should take whether it's a
long-term problem or a crisis that we're
facing that day
uh and then get those options to the
president uh
hopefully we can arrive at some
consensus but if there's not a consensus
to get them their day in court and and
to do that i think being an honest
broker
uh elicits the views and elicits the uh
the good faith uh uh arguments from the
from the various folks
that we're working with the men and
women who make up the cabinet
so that's number one number two goes to
this idea of having your day in court
you're not always going to have a
consensus on these issues and and if you
did it probably wouldn't be a
a great process you really want some
give and take especially when you're
dealing with
the some of these critical issues of the
day whether it's china or russia or iran
or
or syria or international terrorism or
transnational organized crime
different departments have different
equities different uh cabinet
secretaries or departments look at
things differently
and so that having a process whereby
they can get together
have their views exchanged and then
understand that if if they're on the
minority
uh that they'll get their day in court
with the president or you know with the
national security adviser if it's a
depending on the issue
or with the president if it's a big
enough issue to go to his desk and so
i think what we've tried to do is run a
very effective process we've had
i think almost half the deputy's
committee meetings and principal
committee meetings have been held during
the trump administration have taken
place over the past 15 months while i've
been national security advisor
i think it's important to get everyone
together to hear their views
and then we've got we've had many many
occasions where there was a split
in opinions where we go to the president
and again by being the honest broker and
taking that to the president and letting
the the
uh senior officials give voice to their
case to argue their case to the
president to have their day in court
the president may ask me to weigh in
later but i try and make sure that he
gets the views directly from his cabinet
folks
and i think the third part of the skill
crop model if you take
being an honest broker and running an
efficient process and
giving folks their day in court is for
the nfc not to be operational
there's a little twist on that under
ppd30 with hostages where maybe a little
bit more operational on the hostage
front
than we would be in other areas but that
is you know our job is to convene to get
the president the best advice and
options
and then to let the departments and
agencies implement those policies that
the state department's much better
suited to do international diplomacy
than the nsc now that doesn't mean i
won't meet with my counterparts other
national security advisers
i meet my meeting with heads of state on
behalf of the president
but the day-to-day diplomacy of the of
the united states should be run by the
state department
our military operations should be run by
the dod our homeland security operations
by the
uh department of homeland security our
counterterrorism
and and and counterintelligence should
be run by the fbi and doj
so i think that's the third part of it
is not to have an operational nsc where
you're recreating a mini department of
state or a mini department of defense
over on west exec avenue next to the the
white house
but to make sure that excuse me once the
president has made a decision and hasn't
and has had a policy that that policy is
implemented by the department so i think
those are are three of the hallmarks
of the scrollcraft model and we've
really struck you know
we've strived to to do that uh to
to operate the nfc in in that fashion
and i i was just recently with uh
a governor huntsman out in utah speaking
at the warren hatch foundation
and he one of the kindest comments uh
you know compliments that i've been paid
in this job is
and he's worked with i think you know
seven or eight national security
advisors have been a four-time
ambassador
uh he said he hasn't seen a national
security council since frank scrollcroft
run with the quote skillcraft model the
way we've been able to to pursue it and
look that's not a credit to me that's a
credit to the president and empowering
us to do under credit to the team that
we put together at the nfc that
that has been able to to to operate in
that fashion so i
like i owe a lot to brent uh it was a
tough loss but he was he was
you know general scotch croft was really
a giant uh in the national security
world and uh
and so i i couldn't have been more proud
to hear people say that we've we've done
something similar to what he did it's a
it's quite a compliment
i i'm glad to hear jon huntsman's
comments john's an old friend
and i know that he does not flatter uh
so that uh that's even
you know it speaks even better to his
comments let me just say something you
know you
you raise something i think it's very
important you know talk about the non
operation
many of us in the media i mean the media
you know we're always looking for
collisions
fights you know personality contest
looking at
you know what does john bolton uh and
his worldview bring but what you said is
very
very important and i think it's
important that people understand and
hear it is that
i get this sense i want to ask you about
this that you
are elevating other people's views you
are elevating you know mark millie's
views with whom you are reported to have
some differences
my question to you is do your views
matter at the end of the day as a person
an
individual in this process um and and do
you find yourself
able to still be a good steward of those
with whom you disagree as you bring
those
um uh decision to president so it's
really kind of an interesting thing
because i just talked to general
skocrock
and he said yeah i had views i had
differences but it didn't mean
that i uh undermined the the views of
others so
just love to get your your take on that
no i look i think that's a great
question i think it's one of the things
that the national security adviser has
to decide at
the beginning of their tenure how
they're going to uh operate
and look i i've got well-developed
opinions on on lots of issues i've
published you know hundreds of articles
and op-eds over the years i've spoken
out
uh every once in a while somebody will
go find a
a prior speech or a news clip from cnn
or fox or something and put it on
twitter to uh
uh to to show what i said four or eight
years ago or in
another presidential campaign perhaps
and and so look i've got well-developed
views on a lot of the issues that we
face
but but my role is is is not to promote
my views my
my role is to promote the president's
policies and
uh for the president to make the best
decisions he's got to get the input from
his chief advisors whether it's mark
marley who's a close friend and
and and i don't think mark and i have
had any any disagreements so yeah well
what happens with the press is there's
this
you know effort in washington they
always want to you know have a
protagonist and
to get advocates and and put together
some sort of
uh what we do yeah yeah and and again
i'm not i'm not blaming them but
there was a lot written about mark esper
myself i you know i i never wanted mark
esper's job i just wanted to see mark
esper succeed and do a great job at
as secretary of defense and uh but there
were stories about me being
in some sort of an adverse relationship
with mark or with mark milley both and
why i can serve to be friends and good
men
uh so so i think that's that that's kind
of a washington thing
you know my goal is to make sure that
the president gets the views of his
cabinet now there are many times
that the president will then turn to me
at the end of a discussion or or maybe
in private that he'll turn to me and say
what do you think you know what's what's
your opinion
and look that's my role as the national
security advisers to then
uh answer the question president's
question give him my my best advice is
something i did is
in a different field as a lawyer for for
much of my career and
and and i i always tried to make that
advice as confidential as possible
and uh but but again it was it was
guided by what the president's instincts
were and uh
you know there were times my advice
might be something different than what
the president ultimately did
and that that's fine that's not a that's
not something i should you know that
that's not something to emphasize or to
to make a uh
a dispute out the president is the
decider he's he's elected by the
american people i'm
i'm hired by him to staff him and to
give the best advice i can
and once the president makes a decision
uh that's what we go out and move out
and try and implement
i mean i i don't mean this next question
facetiously although it may sound like
that
um you know he had he's gone through
four national security advisors so you
know general mike flynn we had uh
uh generally h.r mcmaster we had john
bolton each brought a very different
style hr was famous for you know lots of
charts and
numbers and i'm just interesting it does
appear to outsiders who watch you
in this role that you are more
successful
in getting the president's attention and
direction so what can you
share with us works with the president
what is the secret of your
success do you use pie charts
uh so so look the president
is a uh a voracious consumer of
intelligence and the information that we
provide them uh
and so he you know he looks at charts he
looks at maps
uh he i think he's got a very uh innate
sense of geography and so
he'll spend a lot of time pouring over
uh maps and charts and that sort of
thing
but again that's to convey information
to him it's not it's not for me to try
and shape his worldview one of the
things that uh
and i i normally don't mention with what
the president i discussed but i'll
make an exception here i when i spoke
with him about the job and
and whether i was the right candidate
for the job
i was pretty upfront with him i said
you've hired a couple of national
security advisers prior to me
that felt it was their their job to
educate you about the world
to shape your views to tell you what you
ought to be thinking
you know i i don't view the national
security adviser's
role as as being some sort of tutor on
international affairs the president's a
very accomplished
uh man he's a long international
business career he'd been president of
the united states for three years
uh when i joined him as national
security advisor i've been working with
him prior
in a different capacity uh i said you've
got a well-developed sense of what you
want to do
i view my job as as making sure you get
all the best options you have
that are available for you to implement
the policy that you want and so
i i think maybe it was a different
approach to my personal predecessors and
uh you know good good men all and uh
but i you know i'm very cognizant of the
fact that that i'm not there as the
principal the president is the principal
in this
equation and i'm there to to uh
to get him the best options to get the
best advice and to give my most candid
best advice
but in private uh you know not not
leaking it out to
uh to the news meet about the fact that
i felt one way the president felt a
different way my
my effectiveness i think comes from the
fact that uh he can rely on me to
to give him good advice to get him the
best options and then to implement his
policies
uh thank you vet i i want to try
something else i want to mention which i
failed to do before because not only
have you written like tons of articles
out there you wrote a book in 2016
uh titled while america slept restoring
leadership to a world in crisis
and so i want to ask you about the
abraham accords and as you said the
ibrahim accords depending on
you know where you sit on this and and
wondering because a lot of people and
observers
uh uh council on foreign relations types
the chinese government see america uh
in some kind of strategic contraction we
can debate that one way or other
but this is something where you're kind
of looking at uh the middle east
and a changing of the map there um
ambassador yusuf otiva said they felt
they needed to take action both to
change the dynamic in the region but
also stop the annexation of the west
bank
i'm interested in that dynamic and
whether or not you think there's going
to be a different vector forward now
in abraham of course and how you saw
that as the pieces were coming together
right and whether it's an example of
american leadership reasserting itself
yeah well look i think it's a tremendous
example of american leadership and i
don't think the accords would have
happened without
american leadership i mean when you
think of 70 years of modern israeli
history from
the uh partition in 48 uh until now
up until recently there had only been
two piece awards the the peace accord
with
uh jordan and the peace accord with with
egypt two neighbors
uh 26 years since the jordanian
deal had been done and and i think it
was common wisdom
in uh you know kind of the establishment
foreign policy circles and and
and uh among you know colleagues and
friends of mine that you had to solve
the palestinian problem first
before you could get to any other peace
between israel and sarah neighbors
and and i think president trump
approached this very differently
first the first thing he did is he built
political capital uh
he built political capital in israel by
moving our embassy from tel aviv to
jerusalem
that's something every president
presidential candidate for both parties
for 40 years has promised to do
but as soon as they get into office
they're told well you can't do it it'll
be bad for the street there will be
uprisings it'll be terrible for america
and the president said look i made this
promise i'm going to keep the promise
i'm going to move the
capital of jerusalem he recognized
israeli sovereignty of the golan heights
i mean the idea
that we were that israel was ever going
to give back the goal on heights is
strategic territory
uh to to bashir al-assad or whoever
comes after him in syria was was
ridiculous that was never going to
happen and we recognized the reality of
it
so he built a tremendous amount of
political capital there on the gulf arab
front
he pulled out of the disastrous jcpoa
which was the worst form of appeasement
that the west has engaged in since
munich i mean it's
it's i'm not going to go through the
details on it uh i've written about it
it was a terrible deal to give the
iranian regime the number one state
sponsor of terrorism
150 billion dollars in sanctions relief
plus a bunch of cash for hostages
uh only encourage their bad behavior we
saw it in yemen we saw in syria we saw
in iraq
uh you know which we've seen in in
lebanon uh just uh
through yemen and throughout the region
so the president built political capital
by standing behind our allies in the
gulf
uae saudi bahrain qatar uh
oman which is a little bit of the
switzerland middle east but we we showed
our allies in the gulf
that we'd stand behind them we got out
of jcpoa we supported them against iran
and then the president did something
very unique for politicians and i've
watched it i've watched politicians
for for my entire adult life they get
some political capital
and they just they want to nurture it
and they want to look at it they want to
lock it away in a cupboard and then they
open it every once in a while and take a
look at the
political capital politicians have a
very difficult time spending their
political capital
and that's just what the president did
first of all he you know he used the
political capital capital he developed
with the israelis
and and worked them very hard not to
extend sovereignty and not to annex
portions of the west bank uh and and to
set the stage for a potential deal with
the arabs
he uses political capital with with the
arab countries uh because of all the
security that we provided him
to let them know hey this is something
that's very important to us
uh and he brought the parties together
and we got these
historic accords and we had three deals
done in the course of a month
uh something that had you know more
deals have been done in 70 years
and it was really a testament to the
president's leadership it had the effect
of isolating iran it had the effect of
showing that america is still the leader
in the middle east when it comes to
diplomacy when it comes to
uh economic leadership uh and i also
want to comment
it's just not about the president i i
want to call out that king ham and
muhammad and prime minister honduk uh
uh prime minister netanyahu uh look it's
very dangerous to make peace in the
middle east we saw that with anwar sadat
we saw that with isaac rabin
people have literally given up their
lives as they've attempted to
to obtain peace and so those leaders nbc
and
and ahmed and hamduk and netanyahu they
showed a tremendous amount of personal
current it's not just political courage
but they showed personal courage
uh in entering into these deals and now
to see what's happening we've got
we've got what i call a warm piece i
mean that the peace between israel and
and jordan and egypt were maybe can be
characterized as cold pieces you know it
you know no war which is great
diplomatic relations but not a lot of
interaction between the people
we're seeing these flights now going
back and forth we've got emirati uh
airlines flying into emirates uh flying
into israel we've got el
al flying into abu dhabi we have tours
coming to both places we have arab
religious pilgrims coming to the temple
mount uh and coming up to the al-aqsa
mosque and the blue mosque on the on the
temple mount
uh to to to see one of the holiest sites
in islam
uh making a hajj if you will there uh
just like they can do with mecca medina
that uh we're seeing investment taking
place between the countries these great
sovereign wealth funds in the uae are
invested in tech companies in israel
this is all happening very quickly and i
think it's going to be a legacy of the
trump administration this this piece is
freaking out
and look we think and i hope that uh if
the the
the current lawsuits don't work out for
the president and president biden
becomes our next president
i really hope that biden harris
administration is going to pursue
the abraham accords because there are a
number of other countries that are teed
up to join
and uh and and look it's a signal to
iran it's a signal to our adversaries
around the world
uh that america is back in the game and
and that that we that we really can't
help foster peace and it's
it it's a it's a great legacy for the
president to have as he leaves office
well look you and i studied poli sci in
the same place you know
continuity discontinuity and i think
what you just said about the opportunity
for continuity here is very important
just really fast you know depending on
how you're looking in this whole thing
if you've just got a couple of months
left you think you'll be able to solve
the
embargo of of qatar and and and create
peace there
because it is a little ironic that our
other partner in the region where our
biggest military base in the region
um that flights their private flights
commercial flights are dependent upon
iran
so i'm just wondering well you think
there'll be any kind of resorting of
that uh which i know has also been a
an interest of yours no we've been
working very hard on that the
president's
made countless calls to the the leaders
of the gulf states
uh it's in our interest to have the gcc
come together it's in our it's in our
america's interest to have
uh harmonious relationships in the
within the gcc because that's a
that provides an important
counterbalance to iran it it would open
up the
the opportunity for more peace deals
with uh with israel
and creating a real economic uh
uh opportunity zone across the middle
east and even
being able to take that out to other
parts of the uh uh
the muslim and the arab world uh so we'd
like to get that rift solved we we
we felt that solving the airlink issue
that you referred to
that uh making sure that cutter air had
uh was it the cutter was able to fly
over saudi air space or by rainy
airspace uh
is is an important first step in solving
that rift
i'd like to see that get done before you
know if we end up leaving office i'd
like to see that get done in the next 70
days
and i i think there's a possibility for
it we've got
we're in a unique position because we've
got great relations with with qatar
i've spent a lot of time in doha as as a
lot of folks in the
on this call probably have and spent a
lot of time in in abu dhabi and
in riyadh and and so look these are all
cousins these are friends
these are this is this is really kind of
a family uh
a family dispute and uh and like family
disputes sometimes those are the hardest
to solve but
uh i you know we'd like to get all these
cousins back together at the
thanksgiving table so to speak and uh
and it's something we're working on and
and we're going to keep working on it as
long as the president's in office is
something that'll be a priority for us
well that's great i want to ask you
about something else you recently put
out a very strong statement on china and
hong
kong and you basically said you know
these two systems
you know one china policy has become a
fig lead for dictatorship
there have been a lot of comments have
been unambiguous about the concerns
that the u.s government and a lot of its
allies have about chinese intellectual
property theft
you know actions in the south china sea
uh actions with you know
uh uh you know sort of techno uh
competition
huawei etc and and i want to ask this
not about you know china as the boogie
man but
but the question of what do you do as a
serious way in response and
just as a friendly critique from an
outsider you know where i see the
posture on china where it is what i'm
wondering is
we don't if if we don't have a domestic
alternative to huawei what is the u.s
industrial policy plan
what are we doing with allies to put
money technology
resources uh defense structures in place
so that we're not just posturing and
complaining
but we're actually creating a different
set of capacity i know that's a
you know somewhat of a loaded question
but i know you spend and your deputy
matt hottinger
um think a lot about china and and this
coming competition or this competition
now
but i'd like to see where the muscle is
in that yeah so
so it's a great question steven and one
of the things that uh
that we've done for the past 40 years
and everybody in the foreign policy
establishment
is we've kind of turned a blind eye to
china if there are human rights abuses
tiananmen square
hong kong tibet uh bullying of taiwan
now the most recent
attacks on india on the line of actual
control up in the himalayas
we've turned a blind eye we've turned a
blind eye to chinese
economic activity the manipulation of
the remnb the
uh the dumping the unfair trade
practices uh we've turned a blind eye to
intellectual property theft
uh we've turned a blind eye to all these
things or turned the other cheeks so to
speak
because we thought it was the the
conventional wisdom is china became
richer
as china became more powerful they
become more like us and it was really a
western conceit i mean i think looking
back on it
it was a very arrogant approach to china
that that they would become
wealthy and middle class and then
immediately they become liberal
democrats and
and quote responsible stakeholders in
the uh in the world
that obviously hasn't happened and we
can see it with what's happening most
recently with what's happened with hong
kong they've
extinguished a freedom in hong kong now
the sino-british declaration had the
effect of an international treaty it's
deposited with the u.n
we were supposed to have one country two
systems the people of hong kong were
supposed to be
at freedom until at least 2047. again
the idea was by 2047
china will be a democracy and so it'll
be an easy integration
uh the the freedom was was quashed
because china couldn't have the
competition
of a free prosperous hong kong uh within
china that other chinese could see as
they were being oppressed with a
a total information awareness uh
surveillance state that's been built
that is something that stasi in east
germany could have only
only dreamed of having uh with this with
the way that the chinese people are
monitored
and assigned social credit scores uh uh
based on their loyalty to the party or
their perceived
acquiescence and the party's goals uh so
they
they they quashed freedom in hong kong
uh
what we're trying to do is stop them
from doing that internationally so
it's bad enough if the uh the communist
chinese party
uh monitors all their own people create
social credit scores on the
people hoovers up all their data whether
it's text messages or social media or
medical records or financial records i
mean
every intimate photos every every piece
of
information about a person is collated
and it used to be that you couldn't do
much with that because
the information was so overwhelming with
a billion people it would be like a
accumulating would be like putting in a
warehouse in the old indiana jones movie
where you had just boxes and
and to go try and find it and collate it
would be impossible but now with machine
learning
with ai with the cloud the chinese
become very adept at
what putting together a total
surveillance society they're now moving
outside of china to do that around the
world
and they want to have a file on every
single one of us and in fact
for many of us i'm sure you me others
that are uh in positions that they think
are influential
uh they already have those files we know
that the washington post has been
publishing the uh
uh the profiles that they're putting
together and they'll eventually have a
social credit score on everybody in the
world
and then they'll use that to manipulate
us i mean we saw what happened with the
houston rockets when the general manager
had the temerity to to support the
protesters in hong kong
and the houston rockets were banned from
uh tv in china and you had other nba
stars groveling to the chinese and the
nba groveling to the chinese
that's how the chinese want to run the
world and and we've got to stop it
one way we can stop it is by preventing
huawei from becoming the technical
technological backbone of 5g which would
give the chinese back doors to pull up
every bit of data in the world
and we've been very successful in the
trump administration stopping that we've
turned countries from the uk
to australia to india to japan to italy
uh even germany now is having second
thoughts about huawei
now we've got american products that are
coming online that are gonna be
you know with cloud computing with
companies like dell and microsoft and
uh and and and oracle and uh and others
that'll uh
uh qualcomm uh that will have 5g
uh either products or complementary
products for 5g
ericsson and nokia are not our
scandinavian countries they're not
american companies i feel like i've been
an unpaid spokesperson for erickson
nokia for the last
year and a half and uh uh you know i you
know
should probably have a nokia phone
myself but um
you know yeah i think it's it's an
incredible thing but but what's happened
is the west is slowly awakening
uh to what's happening we now have
dozens and dozens of companies
of countries that decided they're going
to work with trusted providers
and what that means is they're not going
to have cte they're not going to have
huawei
they're not going to have the chinese
communist party in the backbone of their
uh of their uh telecommunication systems
and what's been interesting is what
sternum hasn't been they're going to
steal your national secrets they're
going to steal u.s intelligence that we
provide you on counter terrorism or on
russian threats or chinese threats
what's really turned especially the
europeans but also many of the asians
is the fact that their personal private
data is going to be owned 100
by the chinese communist party and think
of how what you could do with that from
a micro targeting standpoint
uh in an election if you know
everybody's if you know their hopes
if you know their fears if you know
who's having an affair if you know who's
been diagnosed with cancer
if you know who's having financial
difficulties if you know uh what
someone's dream vacation is
think of taking all that information and
then on a micro basis being able to
target that person to blackmail them to
entice them to
uh to attempt to influence them uh
you know if you believe in democracy and
you're concerned about our elections
you know that's the number one uh you
know concern that we've got going
forward and that all the democracies
have
is what china could do with that with
that uh
a huawei backbone in our countries uh
it's really quite scary
that's great ambassador i've got three
quick questions and we've got like three
minutes so i want to
go you know one of the things that may
have happened i don't know but would
love to get your thoughts um
we don't have any any uh claims thus far
about russian intervention in this
election
so my question is did cyber command and
paul nakasone did your shop
send a signal to finally create the
first evidence of deterrence in the
cyberspace look we worked very hard on
this we had over 60 pcs and
and dc's at the nsc uh i personally went
out to nikolai patrashev and met him in
geneva
my russian counterpart is very close
with vladimir putin and let him know
that interference on election day
activities would be a red line
and look the men and women of cyber
command but not just cyber command we i
went out
on one occasion to the iowa national
guard uh
and and they have a cyber unit and you
know a bunch of smart men and women
who are normally cios or ctos for their
companies
in iowa headquartered in the those uh
the great cities of iowa
on the weekends their weekend warriors
weekend cyber warriors
they stood up their unit and supported
the iowa secretary of state we had that
happening with guard units around the
country so
right it was a combination of sending
out very clear signals to our counter
foreign counterparts not just russia but
other countries china iran others
uh but also making sure that we'd harden
our infrastructure to the extent we
could
to avoid that kind of problem we're
going to have to you know eventually
have another hour together because i
know you're a navy guy
i know you're thinking a lot about the
future of our platforms out there
militarily and i hate asking you in a
minute
to describe what you think we ought to
be doing in terms of reforming the
military
looking at our you know posture when it
comes to ships and
you know naval crap but i i want to give
you that opportunity
i'll i'll be quick more subs more
frigates
uh aircraft carriers with with longer
reach with uh with uavs that can uh
do a long-range strike from our aircraft
carriers that put us out of the a2ad
bubble
and allow us to uh to affect the the
environment
and look the the high ground in the
future is going to be space and the
president created the space force the
first
branch of the armed forces in 70 years
and cyber so we're going to have to look
at things
uh going going forward uh we're going to
have some some short sharp conflicts
that are going to be
cyber driven uh space driven where the
ultimate high ground
and and where where our navy and air
force and army are going to be
are going to be interlinked uh so that
we're using multiple platforms to
to achieve our ends we're going to be
more joint and
more focused on cyber and space
absolutely and then finally
you know you've already sort of
referenced a little bit i know it's
still complicated but
the question is do you think um if if uh
things continue
as they look and joe biden and kamal
harris come in and their national
security
uh team comes in are you preparing a
a healthy transition with them are you
thinking about that and then finally
um you know i just want to open the door
to any uh op-eds that you might want to
send to the hill
well still in office so i'll probably
hold off on the op-eds for a while and i
want to give
if there is if there is a new
administration like they deserve some
time to
to come in and implement their policies
we may have policy disagreements but uh
look if if the biden harris ticket is
determined to be the winner and
it's you know obviously things look that
way now uh we'll have a very
professional transition from the
national security
council there's no question about it uh
they're gonna have very professional
folks who are coming in to take these
positions many of whom have
have been here before and spent a lot of
time in the white house and prior
administrations
and and the great thing is just the
united states of america we've we've
passed the baton
and had uh had peaceful successful
transitions
uh even in the most uh contentious
periods even i
you know i'm old enough to remember bush
v gore and the transition there didn't
start until mid-december and uh
uh and yet it got done and and if we're
in a situation where we're not going to
a
trump second term which i think people
here where i'm sitting in the white
house would like to see
if it's another outcome uh it'll be a
professional transition there's no
question about it
well ambassador robert o'brien it's been
a real pleasure and i want to tell
people that you can go out and get what
he was thinking a few years ago
uh in his book you know while america
slept restoring leadership in the world
in crisis
i'm really interested in what the next
volume will be because there certainly
hopefully will be
a next volume but ambassador brian thank
you so much and i want to also thank
you on behalf you know that powerful
video we saw at the beginning
those families um i knew james foley
james foley was taken with a colleague
of mine from the atlantic
uh in libya uh when when uh my chairman
david bradley at that time when i was
there got involved in this thing and
it's just been an honor
by the way dave there's so many david
yeah david's another great
humanitarian who believes in getting our
hostages back and has been a
a colleague of mine in these efforts as
well and uh
uh no look it was touching and
heartwarming to to hear from them and uh
and again we're gonna try and try and
get some more folks home before before
my term ends
well ambassador thank you so much and we
look forward to future conversations
thank you steve take care
you